huh yeah today we have a fun English
lesson with American actress Angelina
Jolie who is starring in the new Disney
movie Maleficent mistress of evil you
will understand fast native speech learn
tons of vocabulary improve your
pronunciation and so much more
[Music]
one of the things with very logic is
fairies anything in nature has a purpose
and so some water fairies we know what
they do or certain you know flowers that
are with the you know the moss or the
tree bark or the sunrise or the snow or
the whatever it may be
what is Maleficent the Dark Fae are of
the different biomes so they are from
all around the world and part of the
reason they're big is because they they
travel across the world across the
oceans they move they they inhabit all
lands in a way they represent Mother
Nature but in the biggest in the big
forms in the earthquakes in the
snowstorm and also in it maybe some some
other big beautiful way but but as we
all know mother nature can be absolutely
stunning and glorious and you know feed
and shade and protect or it can
absolutely destroy and that's who the
Dark Fae are they're a part of that
[Music]
one of the things with very logic is
fairies anything in nature has a purpose
a fairy is an imaginary creature with
magic powers usually represented as a
very small person with wings in some
fantasy stories fairies might also
appear as these powerful but kind
witches who help other characters in
some way like in Disney's original
Sleeping Beauty with the fairy
godmothers so here Angelina starts by
saying that one of the particular things
in the universe of Maleficent about
fairies is the relation with nature and
how there is a purpose for each kind of
fairy and so some water fairies we know
what they do or certain you know flowers
that are with the you know the moss or
the tree bark or the sunrise or the snow
or the whatever it may be so she goes on
to talk about these different things
found in nature and how there are
specific types of fairies related to
each element Moss is a very small green
or yellow plant that grows especially on
wet surfaces such as rocks walls and
trees tree bark or just bark is the hard
outer layer of a tree as seen in this
image that normally covers the trunk
part what is Maleficent the Dark Fae are
of the different biomes Maleficent other
than being Angelina's characters name
means extremely evil causing harm or
destruction this word is not common evil
is the opposite of good we usually think
of villains as evil wrong amoral or bad
and heroes as good the Dark Fae are of
the different biomes Fay is another way
to say fairy these words have many
different possible Spelling's but they
all mean the same thing in Disney's
fantasy universe Maleficent is a Dark
Fae Dark Fae are a type of fairy who are
perceived as evil creatures but as
Angelina says also have a purpose to
exist in representing different forces
of nature so they are not always bad hey
biome is a region of the Earth's surface
and the particular combination of
plants and animals that are found in it
for example
forests desert and the sea are types of
biomes they are from all around the
world and part of the reason they're big
is because they they travel across the
world across the oceans they move they
they inhabit all lands if a place or
region is inhabited by a group of people
or animals they live there example these
remote islands are inhabited only by
birds in a way they represent mother
nature mother nature is a way to refer
to nature in general especially when
considered more figuratively as a force
that controls the weather and all living
things did you notice the connected
speech that is how natives reduce and
connect words in what Angelina said here
in a way they represent mother nature it
is very common that we reduce
prepositions and articles so the
preposition in plus the article a almost
always blend together into what sounds
like one word in a in a check out these
other examples from friends its
potpourri is supposed to smell it
well that's like somewhere in a ball
look I really need some help okay
why why did I have to speak in a British
accent every week we make fun lessons
like this one help you to understand
fast speaking natives without getting
lost without missing the jokes and
without subtitles
just like dela who says that our simple
and understandable explanations help her
to learn without getting bored and you
can make your learning a lot more fun
too all you have to do is remember to
hit that subscribe button and the bell
down below so you don't miss any of our
new essence in a way they represent
mother nature but in the biggest in the
big forms in the earthquakes in the
snowstorm an earthquake is a sudden and
violent shaking of the ground that
occurs naturally due to Earth's tectonic
plates movements and also in maybe some
some other big beautiful way but but as
we all know mother nature can be
absolutely stunning and glorious if
something or somebody is considered
stunning it is shocking for being
extremely beautiful or attractive or
simply impressive example the house has
a stunning view of the lake you look hot
yes now we will learn with a short clip
from Angelina's newest film
[Music]
fist what I have a little bit of
news well on with it
sozin have any real consequence and it's
certainly no reason to over react
it's just that Prince Philip has
disappeared
nope no Philip has ghetto fever no wait
leprosy no mrs. Prince Philip was asked
Aurora it should become his death
ruin my morning
[Music]
fist what mistress is a title
given to a woman who has power or
authority over other people or a place
in the Maleficent movies
Maleficent rules the magical land and
forests known as the Moors have a little
bit of news well on with it to get on
with something means to start or
continue doing something especially work
example stop talking and get on with it
then let's quit wasting time and get on
with it what payback kid Hey so when
Maleficent says well on with it she is
simply reducing the expression and
turning it into a command ordering
Diavel to go ahead and tell her the news
do you want to be able to understand
native speakers like Angelina well then
I highly recommend our fluent with
friends course we're alongside the first
two seasons of the series friends you
will acquire the skills that you need to
understand your favorite series and
movies without subtitles in 48 weeks and
you could try for free right now with
our three-part master class what are you
waiting for just click up here or down
the scription below to learn more and
sign up something of any consequence
and it's certainly no reason to over
react something or someone of
consequence is important or valuable
therefore if something or someone is of
no consequence or of little consequence
they are not important or valuable if
you realize that's nuts don't you
sanity of the plan is of no consequence
and why is that because he can't do it
so as Maleficent impatiently asked the
idol to share the news he is bringing he
responds that is nothing important or
valuable and certainly no reason to
overreact to overreact to something is
to respond to something in an overly
excited angry or fearful way that is
when you show more of an emotion than is
necessary or appropriate and it's
certainly no reason to over react it's
just it Prince Phillip has disappeared
no no Phillip has ghetto fever no wait
leprosy yellow fever is a viral disease
transmitted by an infected mosquito
common in certain regions of South
America and Africa leprosy also known as
Hansen's disease is a serious infectious
disease that affects a person's skin and
nervous system we can tell here that
Maleficent does not care much for Prince
Phillip based on what Diavel says she is
already expecting news that she won't
like so she tries to guess the rest of
the sentence Phillip has by saying
negative things which to her would not
be in Pleasant news in fact Diavel
continues to tell her that Phillip has
asked Aurora to marry him which would be
very unpleasant news for Maleficent
Prince Phillip has asked Aurora it
should become as death
ruin my morning to ruin is to spoil or
destroy something completely he was
going to ask your hand you ruin the
surprise hey would you like to learn
English with more celebrities like
Angelina Jolie
well then you should definitely check
out this playlist with all of our
lessons featuring celebrities after you
finish this lesson
one of the things with very logic is
fairies anything in nature has a purpose
and so some water fairies we know what
they do or certain you know flowers that
are with the you know the moss or the
tree bark or the sunrise or the snow or
the whatever it may be
what is Maleficent the Dark Fae are of
the different biomes so they are from
all around the world and part of the
reason they're big is because they they
travel across the world across the
oceans they move they they inhabit all
lands in a way they represent Mother
Nature but in the biggest in the big
forms in the earthquakes in the
snowstorm and also in it maybe some some
other big beautiful way but but as we
all know mother nature can be absolutely
stunning and glorious
[Music]
and you know feed and shade and protect
or it can absolutely destroy and that's
who the Dark Fae are they're a part of
that fish fist what I have a little bit
of news well on with it
thousand of any real consequence and
it's certainly no reason to overreact
it's just that Prince Philip has
disappeared no no Philip has ghetto
fever no wait
leprosy no mrs. Prince Philip has asked
Aurora it should become his death
ruin my morning all right I hope you had
a lot of fun today and now that you're
ready to go and watch the full molest
movie in English and don't wait until
then why not check out some of our other
lessons with other Disney movies in this
playlist now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and live your English oh hi
yeah